in the middle of finals week several
universities across the u.s are going
virtual
and it's all because of concern over
rising infections cornell university is
the latest school to send students home
after more than 900 of them tested
positive for covid over the last week
this comes despite cornell's high
vaccination rate more than 98 percent of
its students are fully inoculated so
joining us now to talk about the fight
against kovid on campus is michael
kotlikoff he is cornell university
provost
uh provost kotlikov thank you so much
for joining us on quick take if you
could start us off by just walking us
through your thinking on pivoting to
virtual learning right at the end of the
semester was there a threshold or a
cutoff number that raised enough
eyebrows for the school to say okay this
is when we go virtual
sure well i think it goes back to
thanksgiving when we saw students return
we had
the somewhat expected and usual spike in
cases
however that spike kept going up and we
were increasing at uh roughly 50 percent
of
cases every every day
and that alarmed us and we began to see
a pattern of infection that was
different than what we had seen before
we had prepared with a test that's a
proxy test for
the omicron variant and so we analyzed a
number of the samples and we saw a very
high
percentage
of these cases were
associated with this s gene dropout or
the proxy for omicron so that told us we
were dealing with something different
and we needed to do something different
to stop the raws
what is it looking like on campus though
are you seeing more and more students
getting super sick has anyone gotten
hospitalized so far
or so far is it infection rather than
illness
yeah great question
no one on cam no student has been
hospitalized at cornell since the
beginning of the fall semester so it's
all
primarily mild disease or asymptomatic
disease but of course
if if it spreads and it spreads
throughout the the student population
exponentially we want to control that so
it doesn't get
affects so many students
that the chances of serious disease go
up
so what does that mean in terms of
normal university operations campus
facilities are closed and finals that
are normally taken in person have been
moved online um but are students allowed
to still gather or do they need to
socially distance what does it look like
on campus in terms of what people are
allowed to do and where they're allowed
to go
yeah we we um as you say pivoted to
online for our students the dorms are
open or
our um dining halls are open although
we're doing more grab-and-go food to try
and decrease the crowding there's social
distancing mask wearing
we're
allowing students of course to leave if
they've been
tested within the last 48 hours so we
know that it's safe for them to travel
home
but the university is operating
offices are open the
our laboratories are open this has
mainly been an infection in our student
body
and
that's what we wanted to make sure that
any student gatherings any activities
that involve particularly undergraduate
students
we stopped and made sure that we ended
the semester safely
what other big health restrictions are
you going to put in to keep students
healthy is there going to be a booster
shot requirement coming up and if so how
are you going to plan to monitor that
particularly since everyone can get
their booster at different times and i
assume you also have a lot of
international students who may not have
access to boosters if they're going home
for the holidays so what will that
requirement look like if you put that in
well we've started already
we've urged our students to get
boosters
those that are eligible that are six
months past their their last
vaccination
we've had several clinics on campus
we've provided information about where
to locally get vaccinations
as we begin to think about the
the beginning of the spring semester
we cornell starts as you know a little
bit later than uh other universities so
at the end of january
we'll make the decision about boosters
in the next several days and be
communicating that soon
and that is the we'll make the decision
about mandating boosters uh over the
next several days gotcha but at the same
time you are encouraging students to get
boosters if they do qualify and and
maddie brings up a good point it's
something she and i have talked about
which is that people tend to get a
little bit reluctant maybe even lazy and
complacent about getting their boosters
because
it takes time out of your day you're
already inoculated you might have a
negative reaction and who has time for
that particularly before the holidays
is there anything that you can do the
school can do to incentivize students to
get their booster shots if they qualify
well i think the biggest incentive is a
mandate and and it's something we're
very seriously considering
any mandate would need to be a rolling
mandate because many of our students had
their second vaccine
in august or september
so they won't be eligible until the
well into the spring semester
but what we're really trying to do is
make sure we get as immune and resistant
a population
as possible and of course
you know the the
sharpest tool in our toolbox really the
most effective tool is getting people
immunized and then boosted and there's
now emerging evidence that that's
protective against the omicron variant
which has spread so rapidly on our
campus there is and i hate to be kind of
a negative nancy here but unfortunately
breakthrough cases are just increasingly
common
i even among people who are double
inoculated triple inoculated with
boosters so at what point do you
envision the school kind of accepting
this as the norm just like the flu
students are going to get sick no matter
what so when do you think you'll make
that transition to sort of an
acceptance that this is just par for the
course
yeah it's a very good question right now
we as i said we've had very little
disease on campus
but
recently a substantial amount of
infectivity i think we need a little bit
more information about the pathogenicity
the the seriousness of disease
associated with the omicron variant we
know a lot more about the delta variant
if as
initial reports are saying
the the omicron variant is less
pathogenic
then i think we're will that we'll call
the question that you're really asking
and we'll
have to make a decision about whether we
can live with this virus and
and that also i think depends on our
ability to treat individuals that get
sick and the other thing of course is
that more of those treatments are coming
out all the time so we're we've been i
think from the beginning
making our decisions based on the
science and the and the public health of
our community
so spring semester you mentioned starts
in late january people get to go home
the students will be able to go home for
a couple of weeks when they come back
omicron could still be raging
that's plenty of time for another
variant to emerge as well and who knows
what that one might look like
i know that no one wants to go back to
the days of march 2020 where we
basically shut down and all the students
went home but
is there a plan in place for if that
were to happen or if that needed to
happen have you guys drawn up plans for
what would be required for the school to
shut down once again and close
everything
well right now we're working on our our
spring uh plans and you know the first
thing that we really have to understand
is
whether it's safe
to conduct classes
have students in classrooms
of course masked in those classrooms and
vaccinated and immune
but safe and and not a risk of
transmission we we've done a lot of the
initial modeling around a coveted 19
transmission
and we have a team on campus that's
doing that modeling feeding in the new
data about infectivity of the omicron
variant
and
so our first effort really over the next
couple of weeks will be to understand
the biology of this virus
and then make the determination
whether we need to de-densify our
classes whether it's safe to have all
our students in class
whether we need to go hybrid
all of those decisions will be made in
the coming weeks well speaking of if i'm
a student who's planning to go home for
the holidays i may hear this and think
okay i'm not going to be in the
classroom i may not be able to go to
parties what's the point in going back
next semester maybe i stay at home and
save a little bit of money what would
your message be to those students who
are going through that decision as they
hear about uh going virtual
yeah we we've tried very very hard to
optimize the student experience from the
beginning of this pandemic so you may
know cornell um in in the fall of 2020
had all of our students come back into
our residence halls we conducted a safe
semester we had many of our classes in
person
these uh the spring semester last spring
semester and this fall semester we've
been at at full density and and had our
our
our students in class
safely
again no disease
so um i i really think that the
residential campus experience for
undergraduates particularly
is as a precious time and we're doing
everything that we can to make sure that
we optimize those that experience for
those students i'm sure that our cornell
alum here agrees with that yes obviously
there's nothing quite like being in
ithaca in january or february
i'm sure the students are itching to get
back michael uh really appreciate you
joining us and breaking all that down
thank you so much i hope you all stay
safe that was cornell university provost
michael kotlikoff joining us